despite those pronouncements from big
companies not everyone is concerned
about the economic future of an
independent nation the chief executive
of one of Scotland's biggest companies
Martin Gilbert of Aberdeen Asset
Management said the country can prosper
regardless of the referendums outcome
some interpreted those words as a call
for independence I spoke to him earlier
and asked him if he was indeed a
supporter of the yes campaign no I think
I'm neutral I think the the reporting
was I said Scotland would do well as an
independent country but I also said it
would do well if if there was a no vote
so I think you know even Alistair
Darling has said it would it would do
well as if there was a yes vote but
would do better in a no vote and I think
that's really the stance that I've taken
of course Scotland and your business are
different entities what about your own
business what are the implications for
Aberdeen Asset Management
if independence is voted for yeah I mean
we're obviously headquartered in
Scotland but we operate in 24 25
countries and unlike banks and insurance
companies of course we don't hold the
assets on our own balance sheets there
they're in funds and while there will
obviously be a lot of uncertainty after
if there is a yes vote I think there'll
be plenty of time to work on that after
the vote but you have to manage assets
and would your advice be crudely sell
Scotland I don't think so I mean a lot
of Scottish companies like ourselves are
global businesses and and operate around
the world so I don't think I don't think
there'd be any necessity to to sell any
all Scottish shares if there was a yes
vote it sounds like you're saying you'd
be okay because you've got offsets
elsewhere not that you have that much
confidence in what would happen
economically in an independent Scotland
I agree with the first part of
what you say I think we we do have
confidence because we're we're a global
business headquartered in in Scotland
but I go back to what I said at the
beginning I think Scotland would be
successful whether there's a yes vote or
or a no vote clearly an in this
referendum you we don't actually know
what we're voting for even in a no
situation so it's a pretty unique
referendum where there's uncertainty
over yes and and the no vote I mean
given that what currency do you think an
independent Scotland would end up with
well I tend to think that there's been
quite a lot of electioneering or things
said that that are said in an election
about currency but I would rather hope
that whatever the result people sit down
afterwards and and do what's best for
the United Kingdom even if there is a
separate Scotland and I would tend to
think that that would probably be some
kind of currency sharing arrangement
because I think that's best for both
countries and as I say after the
election whatever the result I think
both sides have to sit but sit back sit
down and and talk because we've we've
either got a deeply divided Scotland and
possibly even our deeply divided UK now
they've been big falls on markets in
London today as indeed there were on
Monday to what extent do you put that
down to the uncertainty about the future
of Scotland and the fear of independence
I I don't think there have been massive
Falls really really today in fact I
thought I saw some of the Scottish
shares arising but I mean that people
don't like on people do not like
uncertainty and hence I hope we get to
the 18th as soon as possible and get the
result and then we can all hopefully get
back on back on with our lives again
ah I know you're not saying how you're
gonna vote but how do you think the
outcome is going to play out who do you
think is gonna win yes or no I I think
it's really close I think there is going
to be a very big turnout which I think
should theoretically help yes more than
more than no because people do vote for
change seems to be the theory but I
think very close very very close I think
too close to call